hello and welcome to how to build a
beautiful blog um Zadok and you learn to
make this website from scratch and these
are interactive ATS chrimbus screencasts
so you can actually pause me go edit the
code make a change that you'd like to
see save it and come back to it as you
like now if you haven't seen the cosmos
definitely just stop what you're doing
and go watch that
don't worry I'll wait okay so let's go
back to our website now one of the cool
things is that it's responsive which
means that it can respond to some change
and in this case it's responding to
width as the width changes so can a
website and that's what allows us to
have a mobile and a desktop version all
without having to build two separate
websites I don't know that I've seen
this before and if you have that's
really cool this is a debugger and it
allows us to understand our website so
we'll use this and some other techniques
as we build our site again I'm Zadok and
if you have any questions or comments
even feedback you can reach out to me on
Twitter by clicking my face otherwise
you can follow me here and without
further ado we are ready to begin
welcome back in this screencast we'll
cover four quick lessons that are
essential for us to get started so the
first lesson is to recognize that all
websites are are really just trees and
to be even more clear than that they're
upside down trees so take a look at the
following we have a tree with the root
at the bottom instead of at the top and
it has two children elements or all
these branches and these branches are
our head and the body the head is where
we put our website's style and any
metadata about our website whereas our
body is where we put the content of our
website so really when we write HTML
what we're really doing is adding
branches to one of these two different
branches so we're adding information to
our tree okay now next lesson understand
that these branches or what we can call
elements or tags in HTML it can have up
to three different appearances now this
is a self closing element it neither has
a value nor does the value require to be
closed this is how we'll most commonly
use HTML elements finally elements can
have an optional attribute and an
attribute can have its own value and
going even further than that elements
can have multiple attributes and
attributes can have multiple values now
this is probably how we'd start writing
any website the difference from the code
that I showed you here is that this
would be a modern website as we've added
a few necessary tags this element tells
the browser that we want to use html5
and we don't want to omit this because
by doing so we let the browser decide
for us which version of HTML to use and
in most cases you really don't want to
let the browser make too many decisions
we want to be explicit here so you
definitely want to include this now we
have inside of our head tag the meta car
set and the car set is acting as an
attribute whereas the utf-8 is the value
and this tells the browser that our text
is a Unicode which allows for all sorts
of things including unicode emojis now
we have a title element and this title
is our website to our browser so if you
look at the top of your window you'll
probably see titles and this is how we
assign a title we have another meta tag
and we have multiple attributes this
basically just tells the browser how to
render our website on mobile devices now
last we have a little bit of content and
a little bit of style
so this is the text hello
world and we've wrapped it in AP for
paragraph I'll just show you in the
browser will look like this now the
reason that the text is not black is
because we've used some CSS to style our
paragraph CSS is a combination of a
selector a property and then value what
we've done is we've selected the P for
paragraph element property color and
then the value of green and that's why
we have a green text web page pin on the
final lesson and we talked about this in
the first screencast is responsive
design which is this bit of code here
I'll just show you what it is and then
I'll explain what it is so as we resize
our website you'll note that the color
changes and this is possible because of
responsive design our website cannot
respond to some event and in this case
it's responding to the event of whether
our website's width is at 8.5 inches or
less now there are tons of events that
you can use for what's called a media
query that's what this piece of code is
but the point is is that this is how we
can plug into our website and make some
changes and to be even more clear take a
look at the following
what we're actually doing is if this
event is true then we are overriding
paragraph with the following color so
we're overriding CSS in some
circumstance or event and that is the
essence of responsive design alright
I'll see you in the next screencast
welcome back now you'll note that our
website now has three extra elements and
these are importing CSS files we don't
have to use our style tag for everything
we can actually import CSS files using
this syntax so what we're doing is
importing a font from google fonts and
then I have two local files in the
folder styles and then the two files
free set and debug CSS which you'll see
over here so I mentioned it before but
this aesthetic is our debugger and it
helps us understand our website but what
is a CSS reset so by default browsers
make some decisions for us and it's kind
of nice but at the same time it's pretty
annoying so what's happening is that
browsers set their own properties and
this can be really frustrating because
we don't really want to assume anything
when we start our website we want a
blank slate and CSS resets are one way
to do that so what we're doing is
telling the body and all of the bodies
children that's what the asterisk is for
all of the bodies children which in the
last screencast would include the
paragraph hello world to apply the
following properties universally and
this makes it much easier for us to
start with a clean slate because we
don't have to deal with any opinions or
properties that are predefined for us
now you can find other CSS resets online
I'm just going to create our own for
this screencast now here you might be
wondering what is route well if you
remember it's the root of our tree so
it's another way to say HTML and we are
defining a font for our entire website
now you might be wondering well why do
we not need an asterisk here and that's
because the font property actually
inherits from its parent so by defining
this for the root element all of its
subsequent children elements will
automatically inherit from it this is an
example of where we can set at once and
it applies everywhere
now finally the debugger that you see
here I'll show you how we achieve that
we are just setting three properties to
all of the children of our body and then
using a special important value which I
know looks ridiculous so that we can
apply CSS no matter what if you remember
back our media query allowed us to
override CSS in some circumstance well
the important would prohibit that from
happening
because it's asserting that under no
circumstances can these properties and
values be overridden using important in
general is often a pretty bad practice
but or a debugger it's a perfect use
case now if you wanted to disable the
debugger you could just as easily
misspell it and now it fails to load the
file and this is great because we don't
need it anymore
and if we want it back we can just fix
it again or you could just as easily
remove the whole line all right
in the next screencast we are ready to
build our website I'll see you there
welcome back now in this screencast
we'll make the following design this is
our website on a mobile and a desktop
device and on the Left it's pretty
straight forward whereas on the right we
have this extra column to the left and
the right of our article so let's go
ahead and make that now art with an
article element and then we'll put the
text article inside of it okay here's
our website and it looks pretty terrible
so let's add some things now open up the
article element and then we're gonna say
I want you to be a grid
what we need is three columns so we can
template three columns by using the
property grid template columns and what
we've done here is we've defined a three
columns each column is now occupying a
third of the website's width that's what
the fr is doing it's a fraction unit so
we take whatever the leftover with this
and we divide it into thirds
now our website doesn't really look like
that that's because the article has
fallen into the first column and so to
fix that we need to tell any of the
articles children that I want you to
fall between the second and the third
column which is from here to here now
what's great about CSS grid is that it's
so easy is that it's so easy to make
changes take a look at what I mean if I
make this 3 over 4 then that would refer
to here to here and you'll see that that
is now reflected and again if I wanted
this to occupy the full width and just
do 1 over 4 because this would be 1 2 3
and 4 and what else is cool is that if I
wanted this to be instead of a 3rd 50% I
can just change that to 2
okay so this looks better but it's still
not big enough if we look back here it
really needs to be real wide and what we
can do is make this a fixed width of 8.5
inches okay
now I open this up you'll see if it
looks that it looks right and to make
this look a bit better
we'll add a height so that occupies the
available height now we won't keep this
permanently it's just for this
screencast now next is if I view this on
a mobile device you'll note that we have
all this extra space and that's because
of the fixed width here so what we need
to do is make this responsive you can
add new Macs which now means that this
column is responsive now go from 8.5
inches down to 0 and we don't have any
extra space this is really great and you
might be wondering what happened to
these guys they're just gone and that is
that these are the remainder if our
website is less than 8.5 inches we don't
have room for these and so they're just
simply not displayed all right now
finally the last thing that we can do is
see how the text is centered here well
we don't have that in our website but
one way we can do this is to add a
utility class this is a really fast and
nice technique to add some CSS that may
or may not be permanent so right here
this would be permanent CSS we have
written it and we have the full
intention of keeping it now
alternatively we can use a utility class
to temporarily to temporarily add some
CSS that would be very easy for us to
remove later I'll add an attribute that
is a class that we can use to style now
this doesn't do anything yet what we
need to do is we need to create a class
called debug center and then our
articles text will update okay so I'll
open up debug CSS and then here we'll
add the following class classes are
prefixed with the dot that you see
that's how we know that it's not an
element like you see here it's an
attribute or to be more specific
it's a class
I'm going to use flexbox which is a best
way that we can position elements inside
of a box so what we want is to Center it
horizontally and vertically this is how
we Center horizontally and then now is
vertically alright so we save that and
opening up our site now article is
centered because we added the utility
class which is an attribute and then we
created a corresponding class to add
some properties to this element the
paragraph and now we can have multiple
articles or what would be a blog post by
simply copying and duplicating our
article now every article occupies our
windows height and you can see the next
article after it cool alright now we are
ready to add some more complexity to our
grid and all see you in the next
screencast
welcome back this is our website I've
just removed these Center in class and
you'll note that the text is not really
readable at the top left corner so what
we can do is add some room so that it
can breathe we'll add a padding to the
top and the bottom as well as an extra
column for the left and the right sides
as compared to our previous design okay
so what we can do is first I'll add back
our class then now we'll add a padding
to the top and the bottom you can see
that that is now updated now you might
be wondering what is this zero for and
if we look at our website our padding is
only applied to the top and the bottom
there's no padding to the left or the
right side we could put a value here and
that would reflect the left and the
right side of our article but instead
we're going to use CSS grid for this
because it's a lot more flexible going
forward okay so what we can do is we'll
break up this eight point five inch
column into three columns at the left
and the right columns will act as the
buffer between the left and the right
walls of our website what we've done is
we've broken up the eight point five
inch column into three but the sum is
still 8.5 inches okay look at our
website looks terrible and what happened
is is that this line is no longer
meaningful we could update this to three
over four which would indicate from here
to here because these are the actual
positions that we would need so 3 over
four represents the content column okay
but instead because it's kind of
annoying it's referred to this position
as a value and just like that our
website now understands where the start
and the end of our content is so this is
a much better solution than having to
count every time we make a change
okay now the next thing is that when we
make this a mobile device you'll see
that these columns are still too wide
and that's because they are fixed now I
can't actually use a min/max here
because CSS wouldn't understand
how to deal with multiple min maxes in
this way but instead we can use a media
query to deal with this so now if our
website is at 8.5 or less inches will
override the previous articles grid
template columns with whatever we put
here so instead of a fixed width here
what we can use is a percent and now
you'll note that that column will resize
with our websites with and that's how we
achieve the responsive design here
okay now this might look a bit weird to
you why do we have a min max if we have
a media query and we can just fix this
real quick instead what we can do is say
in this case just the 7.5 inches and
then in this case we can say be 90% so
that's a bit simpler on the eyes let's
take a look it's all good alright that's
it for this screencast I'll see you in
the next one
welcome back in this screencast we're
going to focus on the content starting
with images okay so you'll note that we
have multiple with images and what's
going on is that these images their
widths are actually the grids that we've
defined
okay so I've moved the CSS into its own
file called article dot CSS and we're
linking to it here you'll note that we
actually have up to four different sizes
so the first two look the same on a
mobile device but on a desktop device
they're actually different widths now
there are two more sizes we can
accommodate for the first three but the
fourth one we actually need to change
our grid so all we need to do is add
another column to the left and the right
of our center column and then make this
one smaller okay now our content has
stay the same because we use start and
end what we can represent a five-inch
image and still provide a margin to the
left and the right okay the next thing
is that we need to update this because
this is no longer true so we can just
take these proportions and then
represent them as percents all right
that was super easy now whether we're on
a mobile or a desktop device we'll have
a consistent grid that is also
responsive
all right so going to our index you'll
note that I've cleaned up the article
because we don't need any of the other
elements we'll start to add our image so
I'll show you in the browser and this
and this looks terrible so we have a
couple of things to fix first is that we
don't want our image to be greater or
less than a hundred percent of the
available width so I can say 100 percent
now I don't need to say height because
CSS will just resolve that for us going
back to our web now it's starting to
look now it's starting to look better so
we're ready to add three more images and
then give each image its own size
now this won't actually do anything yet
so now we've defined four classes and it
doesn't do anything yet we need to
actually add some rules so what we've
said is that any article marked with one
of these classes for it to then begin on
the fourth column and then end before
the fifth and so our website now
everything is the smallest size image so
what just happen is that the image is
now rendering at five inches because
it's starting at the fourth and before
the fifth column now it's really easy
for us to add support for multiple with
images and just like that we have
multiple with images and they're all
responsive because they're following our
grid that's really cool and really
powerful now the last thing that we want
to do is to clean up our CSS we want to
be careful and not use really general
rules like this one where anywhere in
our website if we have an image it would
automatically adopt these properties and
that's a bit and that's a and that's a
bit too much what we really want is that
any image marked with a size class well
then it should have a width of 100% but
what we can do is just that will only
apply the following property if an image
has one of these classes and the reason
that we don't need image here is because
we'll reuse these classes somewhere else
and so this is the right balance of
generality and specificity alright
that's it for this screencast I'll see
you in the next one
welcome back in this screencast will
focus on the text of our website and in
the next screencast the text will get a
bit more appealing every time so to
start I move some CSS from the previous
screencast into its own file and then
we're linking to it here you'll see me
do this a lot in the next screencast and
now you'll note that our article now has
all these new elements so let's look at
our website it's a bit hard to read and
that's because we have the debugger
turned on a bit hard to read so let's
turn off the debugger by misspelling the
file it no longer loads and
inadvertently disables it alright so
let's talk about these elements we know
what the P is the P is for paragraph and
we have e/m to emphasize some text so
looking here this text is italicized now
we also have a link here and to link
something we use the a element which is
for anchor and the attribute href now
points to a website so if I click Carl
Sagan it'll actually bring us to his
Wikipedia page similarly down here I
have a strong tag and this will bold and
text now I also have multiple headlines
it's been the reason that we use
different headlines and not the same
lump is because when we style our
website these headlines will have
different styles so it's better if
they're different elements so we have an
h3 here and here instead of h3 I have
time and this is our articles timestamp
so we have text to represent when we
post the article and we have a date/time
attribute to represent the same time but
this is an a standard format so it's
much easier for machines to read ok and
the last thing is that our article has
an ID and the ID allows us to not just
link our website but link a part of our
website so if I scroll just slightly and
I click here it brings us to the article
you can see that here this is what the
ID can do for us it's a way that we can
make an article linkable and so here if
I click the first line anywhere in the
first line if it will link to the start
of the
this is a really nice feature if you
send someone a website and you want to
link to some part of the website and not
the whole website okay that's really it
for our elements now let's just add some
visual breaks so we'll say anywhere
there's an h2 and a paragraph we margin
beneath it and 2.4 REM is an expression
that we can use to describe two lines
and so we see that here now how do we
know this well looking at our reset the
one line is one point two so we just use
two point four but we need to be careful
here because if i said 'i'm who would
scale proportionally to the font size of
our h2 and our paragraph if we always
want to line heights to be the same
height then it's important that we use
our IAM because one point two line
heights is now based explicitly on 20
pixels and not whatever the size of the
font is so this will give us a
consistent break now less is if i turn
back the debugger you'll note that we
have all this extra room at the bottom
and that's because it's combining the
padding and the margin so what we really
want is to only have a break after a
paragraph so long as it's not the last
paragraph so we can use some logic here
so what this does is we select any
paragraph so long as it's not the last
one
so every paragraph except for this one
would get a break and you can see that
in our website that that is now
reflected all right that's it for this
screencast we're ready to move on to the
next
welcome back now in this screencast
we're going to start to style our text
so we're going to go from this to this
so all we need to do is create a CSS
rule for each of our text elements I'll
do that now all right now each of our
elements has its own rule so now we'll
change their size all right so this is a
start now everything is the same size so
nothing has changed but the point is
that font is a really really powerful
property so we can start here and then
really add a lot so let's say I want my
h1 a my h2 to be a slightly bigger now
if you remember REM is referencing the
20 pixels here okay so let's say I want
our each one and our h2 to be bigger so
I can make this two REM and we'll make
this one point five okay now you can
start to see our website take shape and
now I'll introduce you to font weight so
400 is the default font weight and it's
doing nothing now where you saw the bold
text before is a font weight of 700 so
if a bond supports it you can have
anywhere from 100 to 900 font weights
and if you look here you can see that
we've imported a few different font
weights so to match this let's make some
elements bold so we'll make h1 time and
h3 hold
oh cool it's looking better now let's
look a bit closer at the paragraphs here
there's a bit of height between them and
it looks good it's it's nice and
readable but if we go back to here it's
really compact so we need to open this
up a bit now if you remember if we go to
our reset we decided that the default
line height should be one point two
which is the same as 20 times one point
two it would need 24 pixels now here the
only element that I want to have a
slightly bigger height and so 1.5 is a
pretty readable line height all right
that looks great okay now looking back
to here our header and our link has an
underline so how can we achieve that
well if you remember our header is a
link and so it was Carl Sagan so what we
can do is to tell our anchors to have a
box shadow that looks great all right so
how do we do that we use the property of
box shadow and then I used a special
version of it which is the inset version
typically a box shadow will be outside
this however is an inset box shadow so
we have inset here and the numbers
represent the X and the y-axis so our
shadow is just going down we don't need
an x-axis so that's zero now because
we're using an inset shadow we have a
negative number where normally you would
just have a number like this so this
would be a normal shadow it would fall
below the text but we want it to be
inside the element so we can use inset
and then a negative number and here we
use e/m because we want the shadow to be
proportional to the font size and so if
I use REM here the shadow will always be
the same height but I want to be
proportional this is why and where I
wouldn't use an e/m and then our shadow
for now is just black now what's cool is
that our website is responsive so we get
this for free but you might want your
website to be slightly smaller maybe
even
if you're on a mobile device and if you
look closely the text on the left is
actually slightly smaller it's really
easy to do this so let's look back at
our reset everything in our website is
based in one way or another off of 20
pixels so what we can do is write a
media query that will change the roots
font size so at 8.5 inches we can tell
the load that your font size is now
instead of 20 pixels instead 18 and now
the text changes we can even take this a
step further and have a second media
query but at 5 inches we do 16 pixels
that's really cool all right
that's it for this screencast I'll see
you in the next one
welcome back in this screencast we're
going to add color to our text so we'll
go from here to here okay so all we need
to do is add some color and you've seen
this before we did this in our debugger
but I didn't really explain it then so I
will now however there's different
formats that you can use to represent
colors the format that I like is HSL
which is for hue saturation and
luminance here I'm using HSL a and the a
is for alpha if that is if we want to
make our color transparent so this is
the HS l and a the H is for hue and
that's which color we're using so 210
represents a blue 100 is for the
saturation of a color and a hundred
percent will be a fully saturated color
if we want a grayish blue you could do
50 percent instead now L is for
luminance and if we want a white color
we would just put a hundred percent if
we want black you would put zero percent
and if you want to see the color I'd
recommend starting with fifty percent
because that would show you what the
color looks like and then last is alpha
and that just makes it transparent like
we said so in our index we're not going
to use any outflow instead we'll just
use HSL so we'll add a color property to
each text element and we know that we're
going to use HSL so let's start with
black and if you notice the black that
we have here there's no actual black
here the darkest color that you see is
not actually black but dark gray this is
a nice technique that we can use because
the text will look less harsh so first
we'll make it black and then gray right
so this would be black and you can see
that here nothing has changed now it's a
slightly gray and let's make the link
color gray as well that's a start so now
looking here you can see that we have we
have three colors there's an underline
and then the two purples for the time
and the h3 elements so let's start with
the link 55 is a good yellow and we can
do 100% and let's make this pretty
bright alright that is our link let's
move on to the time and the
a ch3 let's make them both a purple for
now 250 is a nice purple value will make
it fully saturated and it will make it
pretty bright alright and let's just
make the time a bit lighter nice looks
great and that's really all there is to
colors and if we're on a mobile device
you can see that it's scales - this is
really starting to look great
alright that's it for this screencast
I'll see you in the next screencast
hey welcome back in this screencast
we're going to do three things so we'll
add back our images put a caption
beneath them and then at the bottom
we'll put social media buttons
okay so let's add an image between our
paragraphs now before we give this a
size attribute in html5 it's actually
recommended that we wrap this in a
figure element that's because we want to
think generally here if we weren't going
to put an image but maybe some other
media type it'd be better contained in a
figure all right and now instead of
giving the image this size will give the
size to the figure looks terrible well
what happened let's look at our CSS
actually I think it'd be better that we
rename this article figure and I'll just
update that here all right so the
problem is is that this rule is actually
too specific and I know that I was
hammering on about this earlier but now
we need to refactor it so because we've
changed the relationship where the
images are not standalone they're
actually inside of a figure so instead
of this let's change the order now
anything marked with a size 1 class with
an image will then get this property
nice and we can just as easily change
the sizes oh I forgot to add without
some sizes all right and let's take a
look give you three and we can do and we
can do for nice all right now we're
ready for the figures caption and
there's a convenient element for this
that's figcaption and let's give it a
paragraph
and I'm going to italicize cosmos now
obviously we need a break and I thought
that we'd get that for free I mean after
all we're using a pee element right I
thought P elements were supposed to get
breaks but the problem is is that
because we're using this logic we're
actually discriminating against this
paragraph so because we used last child
the last paragraph in the big caption is
this one and that's why there's no break
so so we'll just delete it and it's not
a problem anymore when we introduce our
social media buttons there should be a
break between them too so we just don't
need that anymore all right going back
to our index let's go ahead and Center
this and make it slightly lighter so in
our figure file I'll add a think option
and if you remember we already know how
to Center so I'll just copy this and we
only care about centering it
horizontally we don't care about
centering it vertically so we can skip
line items it's centered let's just make
it a bit lighter now we have a rule just
for thick caption paragraphs and let's
make it pretty light I looked at OCD so
I noticed this and maybe you didn't but
the image actually has a slight gap
beneath it and maybe you want to notice
that just by looking at it but this is
exactly why we have a debugger you look
closer now you can see that there is a
gap here and where does it come from
well by default images can go on the
same line as text we don't notice that
though because this image is so big
there's no space for text so we need to
add a reset here we need to change the
default behavior okay now
all the way up to the image now
technically this would fix it but it's
not the best way to do it this would be
too general of a rule what we can do is
say if it's a figure its child needs to
apply this property and the block value
specifically means that it blocks it
doesn't need to be on the same line as
text therefore we don't need a gap above
or beneath the text
and now it's too close to the image so
we'll go back and I'll just quickly add
a margin all right
the last step are social media buttons
and so we'll put them at the bottom and
I have the image here that we are
importing from here and I'll add Empire
you'll like figure I actually want to
wrap this in a container now I wouldn't
use figure here so instead I can use div
div is just a generic container that you
can use if there is an a semantically
meaningful
all right let's give it a class and now
we can style it because the image is
huge
all right so we'll make two rules one
for the class and one for its contents
let's fix the size so with your width
and height I'm using an SVG so I'm gonna
add height just because I'll get some
side effects if I don't looks good
these icons would never hug each other
so let's give them a padding
nice we've centered a few times so it
should be pretty familiar we just held
the container that this is a flex box
and that I just want to horizontally
Center it but these are they don't do
anything so I need to make them links to
emulate that I have a link I can just
put empty links here because I don't
have a link that I will link these to
yet
and what's cool is we get that nice
underlined for free you didn't like that
could make the underline a class and you
would apply it where you'd want it
rather than just have it apply
everywhere all right that's it for this
screencast I'll see you in the next one
which is also the last one
welcome back this is the final
screencast and in it we'll learn a very
subtle trick to differentiate one
article from another we've just been
working with one article but
realistically we're gonna have multiple
articles and we want to make it more
clear where an article begins and ends
right now
there is a slight change from the last
screencast I don't know that you can see
it I'll go ahead and try to make it more
obvious at the top we have a slight a
very slight gradient and that can help
us understand where an article begins
and ends let me just demonstrate why we
need it oh by the way I've just put the
share CSS into its own file and we don't
need a style tag anymore so I just
remove that we have multiple articles
and to make them unique I'll just make
this the cosmos one because we are
living in a multiverse and the cosmos -
now technically there's infinite cosmos
but we're going to focus on that all
right
so here is our website and we scroll we
scroll and okay so technically an
article is ending and beginning here but
I'd argue that it's not clear and it's
not visible I mean yeah we know that
this is a headline but still it just
bleeds into the next one now the 10th is
only at the top of the article it's not
at the bottom so as we reach the bottom
of an article it'll become really
obvious where the next article begins
let's go to our article and I'll just
rearrange that okay the way to do this
is to add a background
okay so too much but the point is that
so far our article actually didn't have
a background it was just white by
default let's go ahead and make it a
gradient okay I don't know if this is
better or worse what's happening is that
our gradient is scaling all the way from
the beginning to the end of the article
and it's definitely not ideal so we can
actually add another value and now you
can see pretty clearly that an article
begins here it ends here and another one
begins here but this color is like
really really bright so let's go ahead
and fix that
you can use each cell and we can use 55
again with a hundred percent saturation
and finally we'll use a really really
bright luminous nice-nice it's really
subtle but it's also a really nice hint
now if you're like me you want this to
be as precise as possible how would we
for example say that we want our linear
gradient to stop at the bottom of here
if we're smart about it we could say oh
well that's half an inch plus low is
that forty pixels plus was that 30
pixels right we could convert the inches
to pixels and then and put it in there
and that's one way to do it but I'll
show you another so will we so what we
can do is add a value write this value
indicates where the article should
become fully white one inch down when we
shift the yellow an inch down to it
becomes a line because there is no area
for there to be a gradient it's just a
hard line and I gotta admit that that
looks pretty cool so how would we get it
to here well as long as this value is
bigger than this one we're gonna get a
line instead of a gradient and this will
make it pretty easy to line everything
up
instead of using inches we use REM so
that as we resize our gradient will
actually resize as well all right that
looks good so all we need to do now is
put this on the right side and then
get rid of this one now it'll naturally
fade to the bottom of here everything
will resize dynamically based on the
Abruzzo font size so you've done it
you've learned how to make a beautiful
block design from scratch
so again I hope you really enjoyed this
course I had a lot of fun preparing it
for you if you had any questions or
comments or or even feedback for me
again just reach out to me on Twitter at
usernames attic otherwise I hope you
learned a lot I hope you can now create
something that you couldn't before now
go now go watch cosmos if you really
enjoyed this course I really encourage
you to share it with your friends or
anyone that you think might benefit from
this learning these technologies can be
painful and so try to help other people
in the same way that this course might
have helped you alright see ya